welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is a DITA boyanov ska she is professor
of Slavic languages and literature and
chair of the European studies counsel at
the Macmillan Center professor buljanoff
ska studies and teaches about 19th
century russian literature and
intellectual history as well as Empire
and nation in Russian culture today
we'll talk with Professor bouillon Alka
about her new book a world of empires
the Russian voyage of the frigate pelota
welcome professor boyanov ska thank you
for having me let's start with an
overview of your book tell us about it
so my book is about a famous mid 19th
century Russian voyage around Africa and
Asia to open up Japan to European trade
now most people who have heard of this
part of history think of the u.s.
Commodore Matthew Perry because he's
typically credited with opening up Japan
to European trade but the Russian
expedition that I write about was
actually following Perry very closely
and there arrived in Japan roughly three
weeks three weeks after the Americans
and they actually they both negotiated
with the Japanese at roughly the same
time so you might also wonder well
what's the big deal about signing a
treaty with another country it so
happens that in the mid 19th century
Japan the Government of Japan forced
swore any contacts with Western European
powers so this was an attempt by the
American and Russian missions to force
Japan to open to Western trade to open
its treaty its its ports and its economy
and to structure that trade relationship
in a way that benefited Western powers
now before the Russian expedition
reached Japan they sailed alongside the
western shores of Africa they made a
month-long stop in the Cape Colony so
today's South Africa they crossed the
Indian Ocean and Mae stops in the ports
of
Manila Singapore Hong Kong Shanghai and
then sailed alongside the northern
shores of Korea so there was this was
really an incredible incredible voyage
and luckily we have among the crew of
that expedition a famous Russian writer
even Goncharov who happened to write a
book about it a travelogue and it is
titled the frigate pelada after the
expedition's flagship okay so and it
also describes actually the gunshot offs
overland journey through Siberia back to
European Russia so I take this mid 19th
century Russian travelogue and Probate
for insights about Russia's Imperial
identity but also use it as a lens on to
mid 19th century global colonial history
so it's not just a book about Russians
but about Russians on a global stage so
readers of my book will get snapshots of
Cape Town of Singapore of Hong Kong of
Shanghai of Nagasaki and also unicoos
which was the capital of Russian Siberia
at the time okay
fascinating so a couple of questions one
off of the bat is what led you to write
the book did you come across goncharov
chronicle and you got interested that
way what was the impetus so I actually
stumbled upon this project I read one
day gunshot offs biography and I found
out that he made us incredible voyage
and then he wrote a travelogue about it
and I figured given the locations where
the voyage took him surely he'll have
something to say about the kind of
imperial questions that I was very
interested in pursuing that's it I
didn't plan to make it into a book it
was supposed to be a chapter in my other
bigger project it's called the Empire in
the Russian classics
but as I kept working on it and and and
digging in all those issues its sort of
new nodes kept proliferating in all
directions and to really attend to them
was no longer possible with the confines
of a single chapter so I decided to make
a separate book about it okay so and how
other than reading the book did you do
additional research around it I wish I
had a more colorful answer to that
question but it actually writing this
book meant going to the library a lot
and reading lots of books I was spending
a fellowship year at the time at the
Institute for Advanced Study in
Princeton which is you know as close to
scholars paradise as you can possibly
imagine and I had a chance to speak with
a lot of scholars who knew the histories
of the various places that I needed to
write about and they health with by
suggesting books and other reading
material so now thinking back I really
really wish that you know that I had
written an amazing grant proposal that
would justify my travel to all those her
fabulous places so I guess that would
have meant postponing the project which
but I didn't really really didn't want
to do this at the same time the books of
the various scholars I've read
historians of Britain of South Africa of
China of Japan of Siberia did give me
amazing
armchair Germany said the least that
said I I have a lot of ideas about
potential vacation locations which is
all the you know all the more old a
nicer in that I actually do know now a
little bit about the histories of those
places if I ever go there right yeah how
long was the his voyage they set out in
the fall of 1852 and then they arrived
in Japan early 1853 it's a little
complicated but at a certain point
actually the tsunami
destroyed the Russian ship oh my
goodness so there's there's a lot of
dramatic turns in the book but the
mission itself continued until 1853 then
the Russian sent a new friendly frigate
and the the diplomacy and negotiations
with Japan continued until 1855 I
believe at the same time gunshot off my
writer did not stick around to see that
happen because he was getting a little
tired of traveling and his wanderlust
was sated so he decided to return
overland back to Russia which is why he
took that very very arduous journey
across Siberia he actually called it
that he said that no drama and storms on
the hide he sees matched the sort of
adversities of handling Siberian rivers
and Siberian mountains and oh and the
Siberian muds
you know swamps I would imagine the cold
too was yes any surprises while you're
you know reading the book something that
you didn't perhaps expect yeah I guess I
didn't surprise I didn't expect to see
to open this mid 19th century Russian
book and to basically see a vision of
the world that I know so well from my
life now and this is also something that
was actually the biggest surprised for
gunshot off my author and what I mean by
that is that the degree to which the
world of 1850s Imperial frontiers was
interrelated the sort of accelerating
forces of globalization that he came to
observe in these various ports of call
was really something that struck him and
he he he was a very keen observer of of
that new kind of globe more globalized
world coming into being so
I guess what has surprised me is also
the same thing that surprised him and
interestingly there is a very excellent
recent biography by Joseph Joseph Conrad
by myosin off which stresses Conrad's
presence in foreseeing the forces of
globalization at the end of the 19th
century but here with gunshot often the
frigate pelada I have you know a writer
and a book that beats Conrad to it by
half a century so that was truly truly
amazing for me to learn so what are some
of your insights about what Goncharov
writes about Russia's foray into
globalization this book is a very rich
document of Russia's Imperial worldview
in the 19th century that resonated very
broadly with the Russian public's this
book presented very powerful arguments
that Russia must get more engaged in
imperial expansion and colonial activity
in securing new markets in getting more
active in international trade in so in
that sense it was a sort of a an
argument for Russia stepping more
decisively into the global arena
well peopled by representative of all
these other empires so and that is the
message that Goncharov presented
exceedingly well other ways in which
this book resonated very well with
Russian leaders is that it combined very
nicely a sense that Ganser office was a
self-confident European on all these
imperial frontiers but at the same time
viewed these worlds through a
distinctively Russian lens so that a lot
of reviewers commented on that on that
very special quality of the book so so
yes these are some of the some of the
highlights for their readers in Russia
at the time of this particular book but
the
important thing to remember about is
that it wasn't a sort of just a
description of places it was really a
book with arguments right about Russia
becoming more competitive in Imperial
enterprises and sort of catching up with
with other empires who were who were
present and active in imperial frontiers
in Asia and Africa sure sure so let's
talk about travel logs and and were they
very popular at this time and and how
was the frigate pelota received in
Russia mm-hmm
travel logs were incredibly popular in
the 19th century so you know travel
writing of explorers such as Stanley
Livingston were some of the biggest
bestsellers of the 19th century Mark
Twain is actually better now well it was
better known in the 19th century to
American readers as an author of travel
as the author of traveler books not of a
novelist the public collection for the
monument of Nia of nikolai przhevalsky a
famous russian explorer of central asia
actually rivaled the contributions that
were given to the monument of Russia's
national poet Alexander Pushkin so
excerpts from travel books were
everywhere in journals in newspapers it
was everyone's favorite reading because
travel books really combined in a very
attractive whole colorful information
and useful information about the world
but also colorful narrative about it
right so you had a little bit of
adventure and some you know lyrical
descriptions of sunsets and some
colorful you know episodes about
interactions with the local people often
imbued with humor but at the same time
you got your basic information about the
history politics a culture
economy anthropology ethnography of
various of these various new places and
if you were Charles Darwin lots of
natural history right so it was a sort
of in one pill you were to get all these
different types of content so so that's
why these books were so popular and
gunshot offs travelogue is no exception
it was actually an Imperial era
bestseller
even though he's best known as a
novelist in Russia this book outsold any
of the novels that he wrote it was
incredibly popular it was read by young
adult readers and women and government
officials it was part of military
Academy's curricula and also taught in
regular schools the government actually
promoted it as the model for all travel
writing at least for people that it
employed to write so so this is really a
book that you know if you're interested
in connections between literature and
society this is a book for you and what
do you conclude in your book and what
would you like people to take away from
it if it's just one thing what we let's
see well if we think of modern imperial
modern European imperialism what comes
to mind well it might be Britain and
it's Indian colonies or French in
Algeria or maybe the Spanish colonies in
South America right Russia typically
would not come up in this lineup so my
one takeaway from meters the thing that
I really hope they take from this book
is that Russia should be part of this
story it is a country that in its guise
as a modern Empire was second in size
only to the British
and it is as a result of the Imperial
processes that it contained that it is
at this point the biggest country on
earth so what I'm hoping is that when we
think of European imperialism and
colonialism Russia will become part of
this history and part of this story and
I would also hope that reading my book
readers might would actually think that
it would be it is fascinating to
actually think of Russia and to study
Russia in in this aspect okay
this has been very interesting thank you
for being here with us today and sharing
your work thank you for more information
about professor bouillon Houska and her
research please visit our website at
macmillan report Yale edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale thank you so much
you